[Applause]
welcome to the show well
this morning i was thinking about our
guest today gwyneth paltrow and i am so
excited to talk to her about
co-parenting
and i've learned one of the most
important life lessons from my tiny
existence which is i cannot
control things because so much of the
time you know i just don't get that
luxury of things being exactly the way i
would like them to be
and i have learned that it is my
reaction
i can control and we're going to talk
about it when you have to co-parent and
figuring that out not only is it an art
but it is within our control of how we
deal with it with our kids
and all i ever want to do is make my
kids feel
safe and again we can't control
everything
but we can have a true part in how i
conduct myself within
our family and i can't wait to talk
about it because it's such a big part of
my world and my kids really are
my priority another thing i couldn't
control
this weekend was i took frankie to the
aquarium
and we drove an hour and we watched the
river out our car windows and
i hugged the curves and my minivan
through the lanes like i was coloring in
a book it was sunday
and when we finally got there
unfortunately i didn't know you had to
make reservations
and we were not able to get in because
rules are rules
and that's the lesson i tried to teach
frankie i certainly didn't want to teach
her the wrong thing in that moment
but then of course i asked the lady if i
gave her some cash could she look the
other way
and she said ma'am you can make
reservations online
book your tickets with an unmovable tone
and i said
oh god please no i'm not a payer offer
normally i just thought since you were
closing soon anyway and i just think
your bosses should actually know what an
amazing person you are
that you will simply not break the rules
but then i was curious has anyone ever
else ever tried to find a clever way in
when like the signs say no
entry so to speak i love receiving a no
after i've tried everything and if you
have a story without breaking the law of
course
if you do have one i want to hear it
okay
have you tried to figure out how to get
your kid into a sold-out aquarium type
of thing
go to twitter and send us your story and
use the hashtag
worldbendingparent so good news frankie
learned that things don't always go as
planned and things aren't always within
our control
and we went to nathan's hot dogs and i
found one open carnival game and
we played all the money that woman
wouldn't take and good for her
and we drove home happy and life was
good and when you know your kids are
truly happy
not because they got what they wanted
but because plan b was just as good
well that was my morning share and now
let's get
into some important and awesome things
taking place in and around
our world it's time for drew's news
[Applause]
sir ma'am guy ma'am
i asked you a question
[Music]
tell me your story
it's drew's news
do you ever feel overwhelmed by the
tidal wave of news out there
well relax we've got you covered we sift
through it all to find a few nuggets to
start your day and here we go let's see
what
made the papers excuse me
frog and throat hang on
ah the detroit news is reporting
something that sparked my interest
lego is going to swap out its plastic
packaging
in favor of paper packaging
and all because kids demanded it
however lego pieces are still incredibly
painful to step on and maybe they can
work on that next
these kids make me feel so optimistic
i mean lego is a huge brand this will
have a giant impact
reducing plastic is so important my
friend cameron diaz i'm not name
dropping she just happens to be my
friend
she used to get on me for the last 20
years she was so ahead of the curve you
know she's always been
environmentally conscious and she used
to turn off all my lights and my pool
heater and
tell me to go get a hybrid car and you
know i finally i've switched i've made
our promise a year ago and
i drink out of these paper water
companies which i
they show that the packaging is possible
and they taste delicious i really love
them
and i have this metal cup that's missing
i'll show you later and
i used to drink out of styrofoam so like
this is a big deal for me and
i'm one small person i don't think i can
make a big change
and when i see something like lego is
doing this then i think change is
possible
and if we all continue to be mindful
about these things we can change our
world for our kids
but again parents when you're screaming
after stepping on one of those legos
that's okay too so moving on
our next story because that's what
happens when you step on a lego
this story warmed my heart in a radio
interview the other day usher shared
this story behind his latest single i
cry and he's quoted as saying
that he didn't have a relationship with
his father and so when he was watching a
movie with his two young sons and there
was an emotional
father-son moment on screen he started
to cry
and then his sons were shocked and they
asked him are you crying dad and
he said that he took that moment to say
yeah i am
crying and that it was okay and a song
was born
thank you usher we should be teaching
boys that it's okay to cry at an early
age
and he says that empathy can bring us
all closer together incredibly
difficult times such as we're in and i
couldn't agree more
so it turns out men are crying now more
than ever
welcome to the club
[Music]
you